okay here are the questions from the
Internet Oh follow-up question for you
what can be done to encourage more
medical students to specialize in
geriatrics we talked about that but we
didn't say what can be done to encourage
them well first thing that's happening
is it's almost like medical students are
the last people to know right now
primary care is becoming the most
innovative areas and places like
geriatrics and palliative care is where
we're finally asking people what their
priorities are besides living longer and
asking those questions which we don't
ask our parents we don't ask our
patients and when we don't ask those
people end up with more suffering more
costs and they actually die sooner
because we get give them all this kind
of toxic therapy so I think we're we're
just on the cusp of waking up to the
reality that those skills make a huge
difference in people's lives and we've
been dismissive about that in medical
training and as a public so when the
public wants it we percentage of both
care spending goes to the last year of
life so 25%
so if Medicare's spending is in the last
year of life and most of that is just in
the last few months you think if one
thing Americans could do would be find
out how to go where the money is I don't
get why there isn't a bigger interest in
this field
it's the death penalty made right so
what we fear is that this whole
discussion the idea that I'm gonna talk
to you mom or dad about what you want at
the end of life is all about taking
something away and god forbid your
doctor asked you about it but but here's
an example of the kind of studies that
are being done Mass General Hospital
they took patients with end-stage lung
cancer they this a group of people who
died on average and 11 months half of
them usual oncology care the other half
also saw a palliative care doctor who
had a discussion about what you wanted
it as your priorities besides just
living longer those people ended up
choosing to stop their chemotherapy
earlier we're more likely died at home
got hospice sooner and they live 25%
longer that is the miss this is the
missed conversation and we're afraid of
it because we've been labeling it death
notes for the last few years and we're
finally
no one makes without a lung-cancer do
they but they absolutely do 60% do
survive lung cancer absolutely but it's
when you have lung cancer that has
spread and that so a lung cancer that
has gone beyond the lung we have not got
a cure for that so those are the people
that have that on average 11 months
survival all right some do longer but
you're bringing the show down if the
economy continues to be robust what kind
of mandate will the Republicans run on
in 2016 like they need a mandate run on
[ __ ] like they always what do you
think they will run on I mean they
really don't have a big issue dude that
that it could be even better I don't
know I mean I think the funny thing is
you look at the things that Republicans
promised in the 2012 campaign like Newt
Gingrich said he did gas below 250 a
gallon we've had you know Mitt Romney
said he'd get out employment below 6%
then we'd have 5% growth was what Tim
Pawlenty said and all those things have
happened and if Mitt Romney had won the
election he'd be taking credit for all
of them and saying it was all his policy
agenda rather than just you know sort of
random economic events around the world
but I think you know presidential
elections really are sort of won and
lost on the economy and Republicans
basically have had this one message that
the economy's slow there aren't jobs
because the things Democrats are doing
and I think because they have no
positive economic agenda to run on
you'll hear that again in 2016 just with
less efficacy I think you know continued
economic growth bodes well for the
Democrats in 2016 election if we have
another downturn perhaps sparked by all
the things that are wrong elsewhere in
the world in Europe and in China then
that will be good for the Republicans
will be able to say see the economy is
still bad and you'll see you'll see a
lot of foreign policy played out in this
election especially if the Democratic
nominee happens to be the former
Secretary of State so you'll see a lot
of foreign policy you'll see the fact
that you know we'll probably still have
troops in Iraq and Afghanistan by the
end of the Obama administration so
you'll see a lot of that playing into
the talking points they'll be given
Benghazi thank God she was you know
totally responsible for everything
happened you know they called her up and
things under attack it was not bad right
whatever
that's what happened it Benghazi is
either Katherine can you tell us
something about your upcoming project
yes what is your next opus well it's
still yeah it's kind of its kind of too
vague at the moment cuz we're still
working on it but it'll be attracted to
real [ __ ] you don't you don't do the
floor that's contemporaneous right be
like right now want it to be information
I'm guessing it's not a rum sort of a
drama of your show would you ever do a
comedy
I would actually you would yeah I would
consider it like who would you want in a
Josh GAD me I feel like I may have 10%
now that the Supreme Court has decided
to rule on gay marriage in all 50 states
are we entering the final frontier in
gay rights hmm well 36 states already
have it I mean talk about leading from
behind
I don't even drive I think the final
frontier in gay rights is inside
people's homes and communities I mean
you know gay marriage is great for sort
of you know affluent gays on the coasts
who are you know I mean it's good for
everybody but I think it's a key concern
among people who sort of don't face a
ton of discrimination in their daily
lives and the last thing is like dealing
with official state discrimination I
think you have a lot of kids growing up
in religious households in the south
where it's you know they have official
equality and that would percolate down
into into individual attitudes but you
know there's still facing discrimination
from their families and their churches
and people in their workplaces and so I
think it's it's gonna be less of a
policy issue but there's still a lot of
mind changing that has to be done that
for a lot of ordinary people is actually
really more important yeah but I feel
like every time we cross a threshold the
final frontier status for an issue like
abortion we take three steps [ __ ]
backwards when you know somebody comes
in and is like well you know what about
women's rights and about a
portion and about gay rights I feel like
it's a Supreme Court away from
overturning everything that has been
accomplished I mean that's a problem so
you think the Supreme Court could rule
the bad way on this one cuz chance I
think a zero chance I think this was
game over when the court last year
decided not to take up the cases from
appellate courts that struck down state
marriage bans cuz I do agree this issues
moved only one way once you establish
gay marriage and a state you can't get
rid of it
conservatives know that that's why they
were obsessed with getting those those
Court decisions heard but I mean the
courts have been almost unanimous except
for this this one in the Sixth Circuit
that the Supreme Court will hear that
had upheld a gay marriage ban saying
well as Antonin Scalia said the ruling
in Windsor that struck down only the
federal law and gay marriage also made
very clear that you had to strike down
the state laws I would be really really
shocked if the Supreme Court what about
the gay people out there who always
liked it that they couldn't get married
well who said you know this was always
the great thing about being gay is that
we couldn't get married well you know no
joking right
I'm not joking well where it's not gonna
force them is that before it was never
an issue they they could blithely go
through life not having to worry about
somebody saying when are we getting
married that's been taken away for them
what about their rights okay does
President Obama deserve to brag a bit in
his upcoming State of the Union speech
yes but he won't he's been on fire
lately I love that every every week he's
got another new mandate he's a bit
liberated by the lame duck alright he's
a delivery what did the script on lame
duck is he's like you know what you want
a [ __ ] lame duck
I'll show you I'll show you slam and I
tell you what actually I think that's
why there will be some bragging in this
one because what he needs now more than
inhales is momentum he needs to show
people I am NOT a lame duck let me show
you exactly what's going on in this
country let me show the momentum we have
and by the way you ain't seen nothing
yet
because we got two more years so
actually I expect there will be quite a
bit of blood so let the country know
their story alright we will end on that
positive note thank you ladies and
gentlemen and thank you